bertrand roy chat noir il faut s'asseoir
sur la chaise bertrand merci me bertrand
d'être là bertrand et moi j'ai pas une
chanson de votre choix bertrand il faut
toujours continuer à chanter vous avez
chanté la java de broadway et de michel
sardou l'accord berès 20 hockey et je
regrette cette cause bien sûr dans le
saladier
l'équipe avons continué à chanter et dès
que vous avez les choses vous devez les
versets ici dans la poubelle d'amendé
avec ma tête ça va mal avec ça va quand
vous savez que j'adore ce genre de
choses donc ça va très bien allez on va
vous coûter chanter c'est parti musique
kotov quand on fait la générale samedi à
broadway
en réponse au vivat
comment
hu
je n'ai pas
la java de broadway
oui mais c'est elle qui plaît
ouais
e
henri gault
ça
vous n'êtes pas
demain
oui mais c'était le
jamais avant
à
décoiffant
elle
edf
oh
les ardeurs des sceaux s'était passé à
penser penser à procéder s'est évadé
alors l essai continuer
mais on espère
jusqu'à
cependant toujours mais là il a bondi
d'autres bertrand et là il n'a pas été
mauvais mais après sa mort